was always the guy that was like
especially when I drank I would wake up
on Saturdays really looking forward to
getting [__] up and watching college
football yeah yeah yeah oh my god dude
I'd get Saturdays for me were about
getting drunk just hammered Saturdays
there'd be so many times I'd wake up in
like crusty ass basketball shorts and
like liquor tea cigarette coming out of
the windowless room yeah go outside and
smoke and then come back in and just be
a hot girl and like pet t-shirt being
like hi I'm Molly and like hey hey
you're rude you're [__] the vibe I
think Pete and I are going to order
brunch and you're like who's going to go
get tall boys of
Budweiser do you like freezer
vodka like I'm going to put a 100 down
on Texas vers
Oklahoma do you want to go to the liquor
store with me